Can you explain again what the micotox test measures?
So the micotox test is testing toxins that molds and fungi produce.
So the molds and the fungi are living organisms.
They produce toxins.
So let's say if I have mold, black mold growing on the wall in my bathroom, how is that
dangerous to me?
Well, that black mold is going to give off spores, mold spores, and that's how that mold
reproduces.
So those spores will travel through the air to find another moist, organic spot to grow.
So mold needs a moist, organic spot, so it grows on wood, it grows on paper.
So sheet rock is a great wet sheet rock, wet wood is a great breeding ground for these
mold spores.
So then they start to reproduce and it starts to grow.
And as it grows, it gives off spores.
Well, if I breathe in those spores, I could have living mold spores in my lungs, because
I breathe them in.
And I could, if my immune system isn't adequately killing it, I could end up with a fungal
infection in my lungs.
So I could have an aspergillus, fungal infection in my lungs that could cause fungal pneumonia.
And that can be very serious, and you could die from that.
So it's very serious, especially if someone's immune compromised.
So mold spores, breathing them in, are not good.
There's different molds that happen down in southern states, like in Arizona, or I think
it's called red tide, or something that happens with certain winds, hot days, when the climate
is perfect and such, and it can bring in these different types of mold spores that people
can get quite sick.
That's not what this test is testing for.
The other thing that black mold in my bathroom does give off are inert substances, toxins.
So toxins are also produced by mold by a different fungi.
And those have been called, you know, mycotoxins as a group, as a classification of these kind
of toxins that these molds can give off.
So mycotoxins are also dispersed into the air, and we can breathe those in.
We breathe in those mycotoxins.
These things can go across our alveolar spaces, and are elongated to our bloodstream.
And hopefully our liver is going to be able to detoxify and dump them into the colon,
and we exit them into the toilet, but many times they stay in our system.
So remember our degree of toxicity at any given time is equal to the rate of toxic substance
that we're exposed to and the quantity of toxic substance that I'm exposed to, minus my
ability to get rid of them, minus my ability to detox them.
So if I ever am exposed to a high amount of poisons of any kind, exceed my livers and
my kidneys rate of detoxification, those toxins will then be deposited in my extracellular
spaces and then go into my cells.
And once these toxins sit in my cells, they tend to just sit there, and they don't multiply
because they're not living organisms, they're just poisons that sit there.
They can interrupt cell function, they can interrupt other organelles of the cytoplasm, they
can damage the mitochondria, they can cause fatigue.
And if they damage the nucleus, they can cause rapid replication, aka cancer.
So these toxins in the mycotoxin test, almost all of them are classified as carcinogens,
because if they get inside the cell, they can damage the nucleus and cause cancer.
So what we're measuring in the mycotox test are mycotoxins, these poisons, these chemicals
that mold produce.
So if you have elevated level of mycotoxins and the mycotox test, you were exposed to
these, either from black mold, from moldy building syndrome or they can be in foods, coffee,
peanuts, other nuts, grains that were stored and had a too high of a moisture content and
mold grew on it, and then the granary, you know, general mills grounded up into flour and
sold it as flour, and you never knew the mycotoxin content, and you ate that flour, and now
you absorb them across your gut, absorption sites, and now they're in your body the same
way as if you breathe them in.
So that's where, that's what the mycotoxin is measuring.
So when we, when I do this test on you, when you have elevated mycotoxins, we want to
use some things that will help keylate and bind these and pull these out of your body,
but that will do little good if you're, if you're continually exposed to these things.
So I mean, there's a certain level of mycotoxins that you're going to be continually exposed
to no matter what.
I mean, just like the toxic detect test, you can't run away from all this stuff.
You can't live in a bubble, you just can't, even if you lived in a plastic bubble, there's
toxins from the plastic that you get from that, and you'd still have toxins.
We live in a poisoned world, it just is what it is.
So you have to mitigate as best you possibly can, but certainly you're the worst concentration
of these are going to be in a moldy building syndrome.
So if you have mold in your house, that you haven't investigated and dealt with, well,
you're just never going to get better, you're just never going to win that battle,
that's really, really difficult.
So now you can stop eating peanut butter, you can stop eating as many grains,
but you can look at that mycotox test and see the sources, and there's a lot of sources
or these toxins, so you do the best that you possibly can.